well you know it sometimes I feel a
little bit with YouTube it's like you
know when you go to a discount store
like Marshalls or TJ maxx and you know
that there's one Prada suit in all of
those racks of crap um it's how how
dedicated are you to weeding through the
bowl to actually find the one or two
amazing items that are there and I think
that while YouTube has become a
certainly a place where you can find
amazing pieces of satire and comedy I
think that really good stuff gets lost
there because you you'll see that there
are places like barely political and
having tonneau there's a destination on
the web now for satire you'll go there
rather than trying to scour through you
i mean if i were to Google you know
political satire I mean like YouTube a
search of satirical videos I mean you
holy moly you know it's providing a
place for a lot of people to put them up
it's not really helping weed out which
ones are sort of making a point which
ones are just funny and stuff like that
it gives people an outlet to do stuff
which I like I think the one thing that
I find incredibly awesome about the
Internet is is that it kind of weeds out
the complainers because now you have a
tool and a device with which you can
learn to shoot and learn to edit and
write material and start your own web
page and put your stuff up and send it
out to the world and and if you want to
really dig around you can find websites
who you can contact and say hey I'm
doing these videos that I think would be
right for your site so it's it's really
getting the activists who are thinking
about getting their message out it gives
them an opportunity because for years we
as filmmakers and writers and producers
and actors had to wait for some network
or some casting director to give us a
forum and now we don't have to
do that anymore so people are still
complaining then they're not really
utilizing all that's available for them